More than that, Nishimura-san, I
've always wondered since I transferred here,
but I wonder if
everyone in this class can
use barriers Everyone says
barriers and
barriers  If I put it on,
my curse won't be reflected.  I
wonder how everyone puts up barriers No, no, no,
but at my previous school, there was
no one who could put up barriers.
Even my friends want to use barriers It's
so cool I
wonder if it's like imagining a wall in front of them I hope I can put on barriers with auras Then I
won't be teased when I talk to you
Why?  The curse won't pass,
so why am I
putting up a
barrier against Mr.
Nishimura?
[music]
Do you have any good friends at home?  What's
wrong with you, Mr. Nishimura
?